scalable vector graphics or svg is an
image format that's like html for
2d graphics they differ from raster
images like png or jpeg
that use a grid of tiny pixels to create
an image and as you zoom in the pixels
become larger making the image grainy in
contrast a vector image can be scaled to
any size without losing its resolution
because instead of fixed pixels its
appearance is based on geometry
you can create svgs with tools like
figma or illustrator
or by writing the code directly which is
easier than you might think
and opens the door to animation and
interactivity create one by opening an
svg tag
then define a coordinate system with the
view box attribute
that gives us a frame with a width and
height of 100 units on which we can draw
graphics draw basic
shapes by adding elements like rectangle
circle and polygon position the
rectangle by defining its x-y value
on the view box then give it a size
which can take values that are either
explicit or responsive
we can change the color of the shape by
defining its fill or define an outline
with the stroke attribute and if our
styling gets too complex we can extract
everything into a separate css
stylesheet
by applying a class to it just like any
html element
we have the full power of css at our
fingertips which means we can react to
events on the shapes and then change
their styling or animation accordingly
but most graphics are more than just
basic shapes they contain complex
artwork with all kinds of twists and
turns and that's where the path element
comes in
the shape of a path is determined by one
attribute d
for draw coding a path is like
controlling the tip of a pen with a
series of commands
the most basic command is m for move
which will move the pen tip to an x y
coordinate
an uppercase letter means move relative
to the view box and lowercase means
move relative to the last point in the
path but move doesn't actually draw
anything
to put the pen tip down on the paper and
draw something use the l command
it works exactly like move but draws a
line that can be styled
straight lines are cool but what if we
wanted to add a curve like we would with
the handles in illustrator
create bezier curves with the c and q
commands define the position of two
control points
then the x and y coordinates where the
curve should end then svg will
automatically calculate a smooth curve
for you
at any scale this has been scalable
vector graphics in 100 seconds if you
want to see more short videos like this
hit the like button and subscribe
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one